[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 4 mai il n'y a
pas et il n'y aura pas d'accord quelques
niveaux que ce soit avec en marche pas
plus qu'avec d'autres appareils en
région paca
renaud muselier sommet d'afficher
clairement sa position suite à la
réunion de crise tenue ce matin chez les
républicains
les as l'air qui ont cependant écarté
son exclusion du parti
reste à savoir si une liste sera
présentée contre lui ou non réponse ce
soir à l'issue d'une réunion du comité
d'investiture qui se tient en ce moment
même ce sera d'ailleurs l'objet de
l'édito d'alexis poulain une dizaine de
militantes d'extinction rébellion
enchaînés aux grilles de l'assemblée
nationale pour fustiger un projet de loi
climat qu'elle juge trop faible juste
avant l'adoption de cette dernière par
les députés
un marqueur du quinquennat selon la
majorité un texte décrié est jugé
insuffisant par la gauche et les verts
le masque son port sera-t-il obligatoire
en extérieur cet été olivier vers on ne
l'espère sincèrement pas selon lui
l'obligation pourrait être relevée quand
on suffisamment français seront vaccinés
le conseil scientifique se prononce pour
un pass sanitaire je suis temporaire et
exceptionnelle
la réouverture des frontières elle
s'affirme comme une des préoccupations
majeures de la commission européenne le
premier ministre israélien n'est plus
que quelques petites heures pour former
le prochain gouvernement
mallet me netanyahu devra pour cela
rassembler l'ensemble des forces de
droite du pays voire actes'' et avec des
islamistes sous peine de passer de
premier ministre à chef de l'opposition
ce qui semble mal engagée à moins d'un
dénouement de dernière minute son mandat
échouera sur les coups de minuit
[Musique]
et direction tout de suite le siège du
parti des républicains dans le 15e
arrondissement le parti de droite en
ébullition deux jours après l annonce de
jean castex du retrait de la liste la
reine dans la région paca au profit de
la liste
lr le comité stratégique s'est réuni ce
mardi et celle farges vous êtes en
direct sur place pour rtl france quels
sont les derniers développements
[Musique]
il n'y a pas et il n'y aura pas d'accord
à quelques niveaux que ce soit avec en
marche pas plus qu'avec d'autres
appareils a martelé renaud muselier
dans un communiqué le président et l'air
sortant de la région paca qui indique
tout de même être sensible à tout lé
soutien qui se manifestent mais pour les
régionales il conduira une équipe dont
la colonne vertébrale sera naturellement
l est républicain pour renaud muselier
le soutien à du premier ministre est
synonyme de reconnaissance éminente du
bilan coups de son équipe dans la région
paca mais c'est aussi une réponse à la
volonté d'ouverture qu'il a souvent être
exprimée ce communiqué à du président
sortant de la région paca vous vous en
doutez il était attendu à notamment la
par son parti les républicains qui ont
tenu à calmer le jeu ce mardi en
écartant une exclusion de renaud
muselier je vous rappelle que tout ce
remue-ménage 1 a commencé et partisan de
la non ce dimanche de jean castex le
premier
ministre qui a fait part du retrait de
la liste lrm dans la région paca au
profit de celle conduite par renaud
muselier ce mardi le président de la
région hôte français xavier bertrand a
appelé les parlementaires aient l'air je
cite à préserver le talisman de l'unité
les mettant en garde contre toute
tentation d'alliance avec la république
en marche qu'il qualifie de piège tendu
par un président aux abois à peu près le
même son de cloche que l'on retrouve
chez christian jacob le patron des
républicains qui estiment que ce
brouillage traduit l'incapacité pour la
république en marge de conduire une
liste toujours est il que vous vous en
doutez les quelques derniers jours ont
été quelque peu chaotique pour le parti
elle l'est républicain la commission
d'investiture du parti se réunit ce soir
pour se décider d'une éventuelle la
liste concurrente dans la région paca
mais suspense donc dans la soirée on
sera certainement si cette liste et
présenter ou non contre eux renaud
muselier mercier self argent direct du
parti des républicains
et pour en parler continuer d'en parler
même nous sommes avec alexis poulain
c'est notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain les l air à
estelle le dizet qui se réunissait ce
matin pour statuer sur le cas muselier
la défection de la liste la raie manta
cas at elle été un cadeau empoisonné
pour le président de la région sortant
oui on peut le voir comme ça
effectivement alors c'est jean castex
qu'il annonce le premier ministre
dimanche en disant que la liste de la
république en marche allait se retirer
au profit de la liste
défendu par renaud muselier le président
sortant de la région paca en disant que
c'était à la demande de renaud muselier
qu'il avait fait ce pas de côté pour
faire barrage au rassemblement national
de son côté renaud muselier lui d'y
penser d'abord à l'aspect régional de
l'élection et deux pas du tout il voir
un aspect national pensé à tous ses
administrés en région provence alpes
côte d'azur il défend un bon bilan il
dit que derrière il n'y a pas du tout de
magouilles d'appareils et que lui en
tant que chiraquiens et bien compte bien
faire barrage au rassemblement national
avec thierry mariani le candidat de ce
parti qui est quand même bien positionné
dans les sondages pour faire un score au
premier tour et peut-être autre chose
voire plus au deuxième tour donc il ya
là quelque chose de l'ancienne politique
mais qui se fait avant même le premier
tour c'est à dire avant l'issue du
premier tour qui pose question aux
militants qui pose question aussi au
parti renaud muselier dit qu'il est un
homme libre qu'il n'a pas à attendre un
coup de main du président de la
république du premier ministre ou de son
parti qu'il décide dans l'intérêt de sa
région mais il tombe dans un piège qui
est assez gros parce que la république
en marche est un parti qui ne pense pas
du tout à l'aspect régional mais qui
pensent uniquement au national qui est
entièrement concentré pour 2022 pour
l'élection présidentielle parce que il
ne sert qu'à ça ce parti la république
en marche qui n'a pas uniquement au
national à l'assemblée nationale mais
certainement pas ancrée dans les
territoires et qui n'a pour but que de
recréer une nouvelle coalition pour
pousser une nouvelle candidature des
moulins de macron donc on voit bien que
là le message même si renaud muselier
s'en défend de vouloir être d'un nouveau
nouvelle prise de guerre des manuels
macron pour la suite des opérations
eh bien le message au national est
catastrophique et d'ailleurs c'est eric
ciotti qui disait qu'il se joue là
aujourd'hui l'avenir de la formation les
républicains parce que le message doit
être clair et d'ailleurs toute la
journée il a été question de
clarification c'est ce que demandent à
christian jacob à renaud muselier
or la clarification elle peine à venir
et on verra bien sûr ce soir si une
liste concurrente
lr va être présenté en face de la liste
de renaud muselier en provence alpes
côte d'azur
mais justement alexis choix ô combien
compliqué pour les républicains on
imagine cette liste
oui c'est un choix compliqué parce que
l'ambiguïté persie c'est à dire que si
la ministre sophie cluzel qui devait
présenter la liste la république en
marche elle avait imprimé les affiches
elle avait des communicants tout était
prêt pour elle si elle se retrouve sur
la liste de renaud muselier là c'est à
un cas de guerre ouverte avec les
républicains qui eux ne veulent aucun
parlementaire aucun responsable en
marche sur la liste défendu par renaud
muselier elle doit être à 100%
républicaine les républicains pour
qu'elle puisse avoir la commission
d'investiture est toute la question est
là
retirer l'investiture à renaud muselier
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
présenter une liste concurrente
ça paraît compliqué parce que derrière
c'est le risque de voir s'échapper une
région importante comme celle dé
provence alpes côte d'azur
peut-être aux mains du rassemblement
national qui n'a rien à faire si ce
n'est regarder cette guerre au sein des
républicains il tomber dans le piège
d'un parti inexistant la république en
marche finalement qui est un parti
façade dont la seule stratégie est de
faire le coucou c'est à dire d'aller
chercher à droite cherchait à gauche
prendre là où il peut des barons locaux
pour s'implanter puisque les candidats
de la république en marche n'ont aucune
chance d'être élu dans les différentes
régions et ça ils le savent très bien
emmanuel macron est en train évidemment
de jouer avec le feu c'est toute sa
stratégie casser la droite cassée la
gauche puisque au niveau des partis de
gauche à l'union est loin aussi on voit
bien que il y avait aussi un flou total
entre ceux qui seraient encore à
soutenir un peu emmanuel macron et puis
ceux qui veulent s'en aller mais là on
est en train de dégoûter davantage je
crois les électeurs de la politique
politicienne
puisque au niveau des militants ça passe
très mal
y compris chez en marche pour certains
qui disent que cette fois ci le virage
de droite est totalement assumée et que
certains anciens venus du ps n'ont plus
leur place ici et commence à se demander
comment tout ça peut tenir
je crois que c'est un pari risqué pour
tout le monde et qui risque d'être
perdant perdant sauf pour le
rassemblement national clairement alexis
est ce une préfiguration de ce qui va se
passer en 2022 la suite finalement du
dynamitage des anciens partis oui je
crois que c'est assumé la stratégie d'e
mails macron c'est de se positionner
dans un duel qui enferme d'ailleurs tout
le champ politique entre lui et marine
le pen et son parti de l'action
nationale et emmanuel macron qui
abandonne son parti la république en
marche qui a auquel il avait pourtant
donné ses initiales pour lui ce parti
est devenu finalement un boulet
difficile avec cette étiquette de gagner
des élections donc on voit bien que les
candidats de la république en marche se
déguise se cache ou bien vont essayer
d'utiliser des formations existantes
pour faire le coucou et et y arriver
donc il y à déjà cette idée du
dépassement d'une nouvelle majorité
présidentielle avec le groupe agir avec
le modem avec les d'effecteur dans
marche qui ont créé des des sous groupes
à l'assemblée nationale et puis la
volonté d'élargir tout au plus de faire
davantage de prise de guerre pour dire
voilà je vous propose un nouveau pacte
du centre mais on est en train de
creuser le centre l'extrême centre
finalement il va aller chercher tout en
draguant à droite puisque c'est là qu'il
a des réservoirs encore de votants à
l'extrême droite aussi pour contrecarrer
la stratégie de marine le pen qui est
dans une stratégie un peu floue marine
le pen puisque elle qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle est à la fois dans une
stratégie de normalisation où elle a
changé beaucoup d'avis sur l'europe sur
l'euro mais aussi sur la dette sur
beaucoup de choses
et puis des cartes postales à une frange
plus radicale et marine le pen elle
aussi est en train d'attendre qu'il y
ait des défections importantes et
d'avoir des prises de guerre aussi comme
thierry mariani par exemple qui avait
été un des premiers à faire le pas des
républicains au rassemblement national
il suffirait de quelques autres pour que
ça change totalement la donne pour 2022
avec marine le pen qui deviendrait
finalement la candidate
d'une droite fort d'une droite dure où
pourraient se recomposer un pôle
pourtant les racines du rassemble
national le front national sont anti
républicaine et anti gaulliste donc
c'est à dire compliqué pour tout le
monde justement lexsi des lignes
ont-elles réellement bougé avec le
rassemblement national
c'est toute la question je crois que
évidemment si on veut croire la
stratégie de normalisation de marine le
pen au fait qu'il y à une cassure entre
l'histoire
la fondation du front national et ce qui
est devenu leur assemblée nationale
c'est peut-être possible mais quand on
regarde d'où elle vient son héritage
familial son héritage politique
l'héritage aussi du rassemblement
national comme je le disais c'est un
parti d'inspiration anti gaullienne donc
totalement antinomique avec les verts
les rats les valeurs de la droite
gaullienne traditionnelle qui était
incarnée par les chiraquiens jacques
chirac le rpr d'ailleurs renaud muselier
est un des derniers des mohicans c'est
un des derniers chiraquiens et bien on
apprend aussi aujourd'hui que claude
chirac la fille de jacques chirac va se
présenter dans une élection
départementale en corrèze
donc voilà le chiraquisme survit encore
mais mais on voit bien que la ligne
rouge ce front républicain qui avait été
décrétée par l'ancien président de la
république n'ont jamais vous ne passerez
cette ligne là est bien le vacille elle
va s'y parce que la droite se cherche un
chef tout simplement se cherche aussi un
programme clair alors xavier bertrand
est candidat dans les hauts de france
avec un programme qui ressemble un peu à
ce que pourrait être le programme de
valérie pécresse qui se verrait bien en
candidate peut être aussi à la rentrée
et donc on ne voit pas très bien
finalement comment tout ça va se passer
donc il faut surveiller chez les
républicains ce qu'on ne voit pas ou
qu'on entend pas trop notamment un
certain laurent wauquiez extrêmement
discret en ce moment qui est à peu près
assurée de remporter sa région et qui
compte bien rester loin de cette guerre
fratricide actuelle pour peut-être lui
se positionner en chef
un peu plus tard mais c'est aussi le cas
de nouvelles personnalités comme david
lisnard maire de cannes qui était
inconnu il ya quelques années qui se
voit bien lui aussi avec un destin
national
et puis d'autres encore sans doute qui
sortiront du chapeau mais on voit bien
comment c'est compliqué quand il n'ya
pas de chef au sein de des républicains
et nicolas sarkozy qui reste omniprésent
bien sûr en conseillers de l'ombre
en sage retranchée dans ses bureaux pour
donner encore des conseils donc tout
reste ouvert pour 2022 et on voit bien
que la recomposition est en marche c'est
ce que voulait emmanuel macron mais ça
ne veut pas dire pour autant que les
anciens partis ou la république en
marche seront gagnants ouais ça en fait
du monde
en tout cas merci alexis poulain merci
d'avoir été avec nous en tirer sur rt
france après quatre semaines de débats
autour de la loi qui m'a les députés
l'ont adopté en première lecture un
projet décriée par les écologistes et
les membres de la convention à l'origine
du texte
une dizaine de militantes d'extinction
rébellion se sont enchaînés cet après
midi aux grilles de l'assemblée
nationale les explications de katia
technique
même s'ils étaient décriées de toutes
parts la loi climat et résilience a été
voté en première lecture 332 voix pour
77 contre et 140 5 abstentions jugé pas
assez ambitieuse face à l'urgence
climatique
elle avait provoqué la colère des
écologistes et cet après midi des
militants d'extinction rébellion fait
une action pour protester
onze jeunes femmes se sont enchaînés par
le cou aux grilles de l'assemblée
nationale et elles se sont détachées
après le vote
alors cette loi ad plaît aussi à ceux
qui l'ont inspiré les participants à la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
voulue par emmanuel macron il avait
rédigé 146 propositions importantes pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique mais aussi contre la
pollution la perte de la biodiversité
pour garantir une meilleure alimentation
des propositions censées être conservé
et bien les parlementaires ont rédigé 69
mesure revu à la baisse
mais pour erwan balanant député modem
rapporteur de cette loi
l'avancé est grande et l'exercice
prometteur on les écoute
c'est une étape sur un processus qui a
commencé avec la convention citoyenne un
processus compliqué
novateur donc là on a on a le premier
vote
c'est en première lecture un vote qui
est confortable
on peut le dire il ya très peu
d'opposition on le voit maintenant il
faut continuer le travail parce que
comme tout texte
il peut être amélioré j'en suis sûr donc
on va continuer mois sur la partie qui
me concerne le titre si c'est le titre 7
les sénateurs vont sans doute
transformer profondément cette version
la loi climat résilience ne plaît pas
non plus aux députés de l'opposition
matthieu orphelin député qui a quitté
lrm a accusé le texte d'avoir 15 ans de
retard les insoumis dénonce une trahison
ils ont voté contre
on écoutait alexis corbière des [ __ ]
soumis on va voter contre
voilà avec une insuffisance évidemment
la critique qu'on a porté pendant tous
les débats
vous avez entendu nos critiques dans ce
cas d' intéressant aussi c'est là on en
revient un peu à la discussion un peu
l'histoire c'est même les expériences le
10 ans de consultation démocratique les
expériences nouvelles des citoyens tirés
au sort qui pouvait être intéressant
mais passer au tamis du maquereau nisme
finissent dans une entourloupe et même
ceux qui avaient participé il y avait
des discussions tout à fait intéressante
à ceux des à ce débat cette convention
climat se retrouve aujourd'hui fort en
colère et est floué par ce texte qui est
un texte d'affichage politique et
d'insuffisance face à on l'a fait
entendre pendant les débats et tout à
l'heure on votera contre cette loi tout
en invitant les citoyens à être présent
dans le débat politique qui s'ouvre est
la vraie transition écologique si nous
arrivons au pouvoir alors a lieu en 2022
mais ya rien à attendre de cette
majorité leur mais du côté des
républicains c'est le mouvement inverse
il estime que le texte fait de
l'écologie punitive et taxation ils
publieront une contre proposition
le texte évoluera bientôt en passant au
sénat pourront revenir à une vision tout
à fait objective l'ambition de cette loi
était d'obtenir une baisse d'au moins
40% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 cette loi climat et
résilience ne le permettra pas à elle
seule
et ce ne sont pas les écologistes ils le
disent mais tout simplement le ministère
de la transition écologique
mépris de la fonction d'élu envie de
faire du fric les critiques pleuvent
après l'annnonce de brune voir son
député la reine du vaucluse de quitter
sa fonction d'élu pour rejoindre d'une
multinationale le pantouflage une
pratique qui s'est démocratisé ces
dernières années nadège abderrazak
quitté la politique pour le privé dans
le jargon on appelle ça le pantouflage
une pratique vieille comme la vème
république
mais qui s'est décomplexé avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir des manuels macron une
quarantaine de responsables de
l'exécutif ont quitté leurs fonctions
gouvernementales pour voir si l'herbe
est plus verte ailleurs
la dernière en date brune poirson ancien
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique non reconduite dans ses
fonctions après l'arrivée de jean castex
elles sont nées retourner à son siège de
député du vaucluse à l'assemblée
nationale où elle n'a fait que cinq
petites apparitions alors qu'elle avait
été élu pour cinq ans le 15 avril
dernier elle officialise son départ pour
une multinationale accord premier groupe
hôtelier d'europe
je suis très heureuse de rejoindre l'un
des leaders mondiaux de l'hospitalité et
de pouvoir ainsi mettre mon expérience
et mes convictions au service de
l'action dans ses nouvelles fonctions
je souhaite contribuer à poursuivre
l'ambition de accor depuis sa création
fait revivre une hospitalité positive
moderne et responsable
de là à parler de conflit d'intérêts
s'il n'y a qu'un pas quitté la politique
pour vendre son carnet d adresses au
groupe accor avant la fin de son mandat
parlementaire
on connaissait le pantouflage des hauts
fonctionnaires mais les maquereaux nice
repousse les limites de l'indécence
chapeau brune poirson ce tourniquet du
public au privé c'est un recyclage qui
existe depuis des années et qui touche
les élus de tous bords
dans le cas de brume poirson il y a
manifestement un conflit d'intérêt au vu
des fonction qu'elle va occuper une
pente of le ça ne sert pas qu'à marcher
et ça à la république en marche on l'a
bien compris brune poirson est loin
d'être la seule
proche des manuels macron à pratiquer
l'art du pantouflage on retrouve
par exemple si bête ndiaye ancien
porte-parole du gouvernement et qui
s'est vu offrir le poste de secrétaire
général du groupe adecco france
ismaël et meulien ancien conseiller
spécial d'emmanuel macro à lui été
engagé par le géant du luxe lvmh
sylvain fort ancien directeur de la
communication de l'elysée est
aujourd'hui directeur général de la
collection d'art pineau collection
rien de bien étonnant quand on sait déjà
qu emmanuel macron autrefois inspecteur
des finances a travaillé pour rothschild
ou encore qu edouard philippe
à l'époque membre du conseil d'état a
fait du lobbying pour areva
c'est un banquier d'affaires qui m'a
alerté sur le fait que les pantouflages
est c'est à dire les trajets entre
public et privé s'étaient accélérées
depuis l'élection de macron ils se sont
lâchés ça dépasse les bornes
je me suis dit qu'il était en train de
se passer quelque chose est de fait
dix-huit mois après la nomination du
premier gouvernement philippe 40
conseillers ministériels avaient déjà
pantoufles et c'est énorme
l'un des sens n'est pas que des
responsables publics par dans le privé
mais qu'il s'occupe des affaires
publiques et du lobbying pour le compte
de ces entreprises en monnayant leur
connaissance de l'état au lieu de
travailler à la création de richesse si
ses anciens responsables et politiques
n'ont pas été inquiétés d'autres se sont
vu retoquer par la commission de
déontologie de la fonction publique
encadrée par l'article 432-13 du code
pénal relatif aux délits de prise
illégale d'intérêt la pratique peut être
condamnée si elle ne respecte pas
l'expiration d'un délai de trois ans
suivant la cessation des fonctions
exécutif a récemment l'ancien conseiller
sanitaire d'olivier verront grégory
hémeury s'est vu empêcher de rejoindre
le groupe gériatrique courrian au motif
que ses fonctions pourrait créer un
conflit d'intérêts et favoriser
l'entreprise en l'informant des
décisions gouvernementales
bernard soir chimie ancien directeur
central du renseignement intérieur
reconverti en consultant indépendant est
quant à lui accusé d'avoir misé
à profit ces méthodes d'espionnage pour
le compte de son client lvmh de rares
exemples qui ne dissuade pas pour autant
certain de porter la pantoufle mieux qu
un soulier d'or
quelles conséquences de la grippe
aviaire sur le monde agricole en pleine
crise sanitaire en janvier dernier arte
france a recueilli le témoignage d'un
éleveur de canards qui se battait contre
ce virus
quatre mois plus tard leila sarah fait
avec grand chances sont à nouveau aller
à sa rencontre
les machines ne tournent pas il n'y a
plus un seul canard c'est la première
fois que lionel candelon revient sur son
exploitation
depuis que ces animaux sont partis sur
ordre de l'état se faire euthanasier
c'est la gorge nouée par l'émotion qu'il
nous décrit lusage aujourd'hui perdu de
ses bâtiments
ça c'est l'unité un des deux unités de
croissance ou donc il y avait les
beckham a requis 1 qui ont été abattus
et donc vous là c'est pareil depuis
l'abattage un des bâtiments sont survie
d'un vide de vivies de vie de travail
vie de philippe nous montre le champ où
les canards sont élevés en plein air
tout en marchant il raconte l'épisode
douloureux où il a été obligé de charger
ses bêtes pour les envoyer à l'abattoir
la première phase la plus dure
psychologiquement ça a été de charger
des animaux soi-même vivant dans le
camion qui à l'ailé
les amener à l'abattage ou l'euthanasie
ça a été ça a été une journée vraiment
éprouvant psychologiquement
aujourd'hui la situation financière de
lionel est préoccupante peu indemnisées
par l'état y ne peut plus se verser de
salaires depuis plusieurs mois
résultat son compte en banque et dans le
rouge avec plus de 1000 euros
d'endettement pour s'en sortir et la
film de monde pour percevoir le rsa
en attendant des jours meilleurs restez
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du comique 19 en france port
du masque cet été parce sanitaire
vaccination et puis l'espoir peut-être
des traitements notamment avec celui de
la biotech nantaise xénon terra ou d'il
divo serai présidente jeu nous en
parlera et puis direction israël où
benyamin nétanyahou n'a plus que
quelques heures pour former un
gouvernement à la tête du pays depuis
douze ans il pourrait devenir chef de
l'opposition de ce soir à minuit
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bien enroulé
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry allons
faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bahia là on
est alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge et
autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous un peu long des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité comment
souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qu'il défendit il n'y a
pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pj les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors jean
francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage une montagne de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
ont été beaucoup moins regardante sur la
provenance de cet argent qui arrivait
pour renflouer les caisses ça a été même
dire nations unies on a constaté que
plusieurs dizaines de milliards issus du
trafic de stupéfiants ont été absorbés
par un certain nombre de banques aux
états unis qui d'ailleurs ont été
poursuivis en justice et ont payé des
amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez en france
le port du masque sera-t-il encore
obligatoire en extérieur cet été olivier
ferrand ne l'espère sincèrement pas
c'est ce qu'il a expliqué ce matin au
micro d'europe 1 selon lui l'obligation
pourraient être levés quand suffisamment
de français seront vaccinés jeu si nous
pourrons alors baissé la garde en
attendant ils appellent à la prudence
alors que pour l'heure un peu moins de
16 millions de français ont au moins
reçu une première dose
la maîtrise de l'épidémie s'accélère
discrètement mais il ne faut pas
relâcher trop vite
en ce sens le calendrier de
déconfinement est en très bon calendrier
nous pensons très fortement que la
vaccination protège bien du risque de
contamination est donc de diffusion du
virus et donc du risque d'épidémies
parmi les personnes vaccinées une large
majorité des résidents des ehpad les
maisons de retraite ou les libertés
id en auraient été bafoués pendant la
crise sanitaire selon la défenseur des
droits claire hédon a rendu ce matin son
rapport au sein duquel à des centaines
de témoignages dénoncent des violations
de libertés dans ces établissements
il est notamment question de tests
optiques ovide réalisé sans consentement
du maintien des restrictions de
mouvements hors périodes de confinement
ou encore de l'interdiction sortir même
pour les résidents vacciner l'examen de
ces réclamations montre de manière
récurrente des atteintes aux droits
fondamentaux au respect de la dignité et
l'intégrité des personnes accueillies le
droit à la vie privée et familiale a
donc été grandement entravé au cours de
la crise sanitaire et de façon bien plus
importante pour les personnes résidents
en ehpad que pour le reste de la
population
la crise sanitaire a mis en évidence les
difficultés pour les pouvoirs publics à
concilier les enjeux de santé publique
avec la nécessité d'une réponse
appropriée aux besoins spécifiques des
personnes âgées accueillies en ehpad
afin de préserver non seulement leur
santé mais aussi leurs droits et
libertés et le pass sanitaire validé par
le conseil scientifique le certificat
lancé depuis le début de la semaine les
français vaccinés contre le commis 19 2
reçoivent une attestation enregistrées
sur l'application tout senti qu vide
si aujourd'hui ce papier ne permet aucun
passe-droit la donne pourrait changer
cet été les détails avec médiers ski fis
validé par le conseil scientifique s'il
s'applique de manière temporaire et
exceptionnelle
le pass sanitaires commencent à prendre
forme un qr code placé sur les
attestations de vaccination a scanné
ensuite sur l'application tout senti qu
vide
voilà en quoi consiste le certificat
vaccinale appelé à se développer dans
l'hexagone une première étape dans
l'instauration de ce procédé numérique
dont le principe a été voté par le
parlement européen
fin avril le pass sanitaire utilisé de
manière temporaire et exceptionnelle
peut permettre à la population une forme
de retour à la vie normale en minimisant
les risques de contamination par le
virus sarr skov de ce pass and i ter
sera le sésame pour accéder aux
événements sportifs festifs mais aussi
culturelles comme l'a dernièrement
rappelé emmanuel mac
en revanche pas de dispositions prévues
pour les bars et les restaurants
il y a un double aspect la reprise de
l'activité économique et la maîtrise de
l'épidémie et des variants mais
attention parce sanitaire ne veut pas
dire protection absolue
cet outil numérique a pour but
d'empêcher toute fraude en garantissant
la fiabilité des attestations un procédé
toutefois loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de l'opposition
pas de passes sanitaire si le vaccin
n'est pas accessible à tous d'où la
nécessité de lever les brevets le
rapport était clair les amendements ont
bien été déposés par notre groupe où
siège la france insoumise prendre
position pour la levée des brevets c'est
bien le voter c'est mieux et pour tous
ceux qui se posent la question
nous nous sommes bien opposés au passage
ni terre qui marque un nouveau recul des
libertés
la position de la france insoumise et
très clair là dessus
l'épidémiologiste en chef emmanuel
macron nous en qui l'air de rien le
passeport vaccinale pour moi il n'est
pas question de droit d'accès à deux
vitesses outre les risques de
stigmatisation qu'il soulève se passe à
l'inconvénient de ne pas reconnaître
tous les vaccins
seuls sont concernés pour l'instant les
sérums autorisés par l'ue eux à savoir
ceux de pfizer biotech astrazeneca
moderna & johnson and johnson et face au
virus l'espoir aussi des traitements la
biotech notait des notaires adhémar la
dernière étape des essais cliniques du
xav 19 son traitement kiko vide en
attendant les résultats de phase ii
prévue pour l'été 2000 21
pour en parler nous sommes justement
avec odile dumeaux président de xénon
terra
et bonsoir odile dumeaux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france la phase iii donc une nouvelle
très une étape très importante pour
votre traitement anti qu'ovide les
espérances sont grandes
bah oui les expériences une désespérance
pardon sont évidemment très grande
bonsoir à tous nous savons que
malheureusement il n'existe toujours pas
de traitement actif pour guérir les gens
qui souffrent notamment des phases
aggravé de convives 19
alors bien sûr comme vous venez de le
souligner la vaccination constitue un
énorme espoir pour réduire le nombre de
personnes qui ont besoin d'être traités
mais il reste des malades
il en restera malheureusement toujours
et pour ces gens là un espoir de
traitement c'est indispensable
donc qu'est ce que c'est qu'une phase
iii c'est une phase quantitative où on a
déjà 400 passion donc on est déjà sur un
grand nombre de patients qui me permet
d'être confiants et là nous allons
rajouter un essai sur 722 patients qui
va se dérouler dans toute l'europe
alors on va parler de ce fameux
traitement parce que c'est vrai qu'on en
a pas beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
on a laissé la part belle aux part belle
aux vaccins on laisse un petit peu de
côté ces traitements ils font partie des
anticorps polyclonaux qu'est ce que
c'est exactement alors c'est un
anticorps dirigés contre le virus alors
davantage c'est comme il est polyclonale
il marche contre les variants alors vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui les variants c'est
un vrai souci parce qu'on sait que les
enfants des autres anticorps qu'on
appelle monoclonaux e pour le coup
présente vraiment un risque de
d'inactivation totale avec les variants
les polyclonaux ne subissent pas ce
risque là donc c'est un anticorps il va
détruire le virus
il va neutraliser le virus et en plus il
va avoir un effet très spécifiques de
notre technologie puisqu'il va limiter
l'inflammation liée au virus
au total nous espérons bien qu'il
permettra de guérir les gens qui sont
dans la phase dite modérée
ça veut dire quoi exactement deal
du veau la phase dite modérée ça veut
dire si on vous suit que quel que soit
le variant du virus qu'on attrape
brésilien sud-africain britannique euros
on peut une fois qu'on est testé positif
prendre ce traitement alors le principe
de notre traitement c'est que quand vous
le savez quand on attrape lakovic 19 on
commence par une phase qui est
relativement bénigne et qui heureusement
rarement risque de s'aggraver alors la
phase bénigne elle du rambo 5 jours et
au vième entre le 6e et le neuvième jour
précisément là il ya un risque de
démarrer une pneumopathie
c'est à ce moment là que le greffe 19
ans toute sa place puisqu'il va empêcher
cette phase
au moment de cette phase d'aggravation
il va empêcher le risque de passer à une
phase beaucoup plus grave on risque
d'aller en réanimation ou en soins
intensifs
donc il est destiné à des gens qui
aujourd'hui pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur sont de 1500 à 2000 personnes
par jour en france qui auraient besoin
d'un traitement comme le 19 donc c'est
un besoin qui est relativement limitée
par rapport au nombre de cas que nous
voyons tous les jours encore
malheureusement mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que c'est un besoin réel pour les
patients qui sont dans les hôpitaux
ça veut dire qu'une fois qu'on a été
vaccinée on peut tout de même prendre ce
traitement ou ça ne sert à rien alors ça
c'est un grand mystère puisque le sujet
c'est l'efficacité le sujet que vous
soulevez c'est l'efficacité de la
vaccination
donc on sait aujourd'hui que la
vaccination empêche la plupart des gens
d'arriver à un pack très grave de la
maladie
c'est les premiers essais cliniques qui
l'on est et qui ont l'ont démontré
notamment aux états unis
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'on est
encore en pas en mesure absolue de
savoir si les gens qui sont vaccinées
peuvent mal
et tous tombés malades et se retrouver
nos stades dits modérés ou là il sera
tout à fait intéressant de suppléer
leurs propres anticorps par l'exotisme
donc ça c'est quelque chose que nous
ignorons pour l'instant en tout cas nous
nous avons dans nos essais cliniques
recruter enfin proposé le 19 à des gens
qui étaient en début de spécialisation
fixes soient vaccinées ou non et ça fera
partie des choses que nous étudierons
lorsque nous déposerons les résultats
d'essais alors la question qu'on se pose
pourquoi cet essai se déroule-t-il en
grèce en bulgarie en roumanie en espagne
et en turquie
et pas en france alors que vous êtes une
société française
alors on est une société française on a
démarré donc notre projet xav 19 en mars
2020 nous allons donc était prêt pour la
clinique dès le mois de mai 2020 parce
que notre technologie était très mature
et donc nous avons ensuite fort
naturellement proposé aux autorités
françaises de faire un essai clinique en
france et c'est ce qui a été fait et qui
a été d'ailleurs soutenu par le
gouvernement en association avec le
siège cheminante qui a fait un travail
remarquable de promotion et de
mobilisation de 35 hôpitaux en france et
avec l'université de nantes
l'essai français laissait polycor 400
patients vient de finir ses recrutements
et en parallèle de celle nous a semblé
naturel
en plus nous avions eu un financement
européen de proposer à d'autres pays en
europe qui ont aussi des pratiques
thérapeutiques et d'hospitalisation
différente de voir quelques courbettes
l'intérêt sur d'autres pays donc ce
n'est pas que nous ne sommes pas en
france c'est que au delà de la france
nous faisons un essai dans d'autres pays
pour vous donner une idée dans certains
pays les infrastructures hospitalières
étant différente
les personnes qui aujourd'hui en france
sont hospitalisées pour être surveillés
même si elles ne sont pas dans un état
grave
vont dans d'autres pays être renvoyée
chez elle est simplement surveiller à
distance par des coups de téléphone
journalier donc les pratiques sont
différentes et nous pensons que pour ces
malades aussi par exemple c'est
extrêmement intéressant de recevoir 10 à
19 d'où l'intérêt de faire un essai dans
d'autres pays
est ce que vous avez
déjà reçu des précommandes
la commission européenne qui on le sait
j'ai re voilà il centralise les
commandes pour l'union européenne
alors nous avons eu des discussions avec
ce qui sera la future agence européenne
des épidémies donc l'équivalent du barda
américain nous avons eu des discussions
depuis quelques semaines sur le sujet
mais nous n'avons à ce stade pas signé
de précommande avec la commission
européenne
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres pays avec
lesquels vous auriez signé des commandes
j'ai pas si vous voyez où je veux en
venir mais c'est vrai qu'on entendait le
pdg de modern à nous dire assez tôt en
amont que voilà il s'étonnait pas avoir
eu de commandes de son vaccin moderna
qui fonctionnait déjà et qui étaient
commandés surtout au royaume uni et aux
états unis et aucune commande en europe
est ce qu'on suit le même chemin avec
votre traitement ou est ce que la
commission européenne s'est améliorée
entre temps alors écoutez il ne
m'appartient pas de juger les évolutions
et les progrès de la commission
européenne c'est assez certain moi ce
que je peux te dire vue de la fenêtre
d'une biotech c'est que et peut-être que
c'est un peu le cadre moderne a aussi
c'est que quand on est une entreprise
relativement jeunes avec des ressources
limitées en nombre
on n'est pas en mesure de faire j'allais
dire une action commerciale de
proposition vis-à-vis de toutes les
structures du monde entier nous
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une phase
du médicament extrêmement pour un genre
qui fait que nous avons un certain
nombre de gens qui nous contactent pour
pouvoir nous réserver du médicament etc
des sujets sur lesquels nous avançons
pas à pas j'avais dire est beaucoup plus
en mesure de communiquer dans les
prochains mois il est certain que en
tant que biotech française soutenue et
financée largement par le gouvernement
français et par l'europe depuis le
démarrage du projet coheed moins que
d'autres mais quand même de façon
significative nous pouvons
moi il me semble normal de proposer en
priorité notre traitement au
gouvernement ou à l'europe
donc c'est ce que nous avons fait et
c'est pour ça que nous privilégions la
discussion avec l'europe
indépendamment des demandes qui ne sont
fait d'autres parties du monde
aujourd'hui clairement dit le du mot
vous avez les moyens de produire de
manière industrielle alors nous avons
fait un énorme effort chez xénon terrain
pour vous dire on était quand même moins
d'ici un an on est pratiquement 20
aujourd'hui on va grossi fit alors ça
peut sembler encore très peu nombreux et
puis surtout nous avons des partenaires
et notamment un partenaire français qui
est le lfb qui est impliqué dans le
manufacturing et avec lequel nous avons
travaillé sur l'industrialisation de
l'ensemble de nos procédés le but étant
effectivement de pouvoir couvrir les
besoins du marché avec une phase
d'industrialisation extrêmement rapide
en gros pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
à partir de janvier 2022
les lots donc les groupes de médicaments
centrales chaque fois de médicaments
sera quasiment 100 fois plus gros que ce
que je faisais en 2020 donc on aura
multiplié notre échelle de production
par cent ce qui est absolument colossal
et qui n'en pour une industrie
pharmaceutique représentent des efforts
de validation de l'ensemble des étapes
du procédé qui sont loin d'être
négligeables
techniquement ce n'est pas ça une toute
dernière question les résultats donc la
phase 2 1 fin juin 6
c'était conclure quand est ce que oui
quand est ce qu'on peut espérer voir ce
traitement sur le marché alors alors ça
ne dépend pas que douvin fera dépend
aussi des agences et notamment de
l'année celle donc nous commençons à
dialoguer avec les mécènes de façon à
pouvoir dès l'obtention de résultats
être en mesure de proposer ce traitement
et notamment au cours des patients de la
vague du mois d'automne que j'espère
aussi plate que possible que ce soit
bien clair
merci beaucoup du veau présidente de
xénon terra d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france demain marquera le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
bonaparte 200 ans après sa mort napoléon
reste emblématique pour certains russes
qui collectionne de nombreuses pièces
ayant appartenu à l'empereur dans un
pays qu'il a tenté en vain d'envahir
napoléon bonaparte est vu comme un grand
homme voire un héros romantique des
collections en russie mais aussi en
france à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de
sa mort une exposition se tient au
château de fontainebleau avant une vente
aux enchères prévue demain nicolas petit
des statues des tableaux et même des
épées ce sont en tout 350 objets à la
mémoire de napoléon 1er qui sont réunis
depuis ce week end au château de
fontainebleau
une collection exceptionnelle qui
matérialise la vie et les derniers
instants de celui qui a conquis une
grande partie de l'europe pour y porter
le fer de la révolution là vous avez les
derniers effets personnels de napoléon
1er est notamment
anne ces derniers mouchoirs également
voir des traces de sang ce qui était
très caractéristique de la fin de sa vie
de sa maladie et les bandelettes de le
club si parmi les pièces rares qui
seront aussi mises aux enchères mercredi
et jeudi des manuscrits son légendaire
chapeau le traîneau de joséphine ou
encore les bas de l'officier
d'artillerie devenu empereur
on sent des bas de soie vous avez
toujours cette petite bande brodé ici
et toujours pleine couronnée de napoléon
bien que la date du 5 mai pourrait faire
grimper les enchères
certains tableaux figurines et livres de
cette exposition sont estimées à moins
de 150 euros
de quoi combler de nombreux amateurs de
la grande épopée napoléonienne en israël
maillet me netanyahu n'a plus que
quelques petites heures pour former son
gouvernement faute de quoi le premier
ministre sans interruption au pouvoir
depuis 2009 devrait se retrouver chef de
l'opposition ce mardi à minuit lors des
dernières législatives en mars le likoud
était arrivé en tête du scrutin avec 30
sièges
le premier ministre sortant n'était pas
parvenu à convaincre les leaders des
autres partis à le rejoindre et à former
une majorité de 61 députés pour pouvoir
gouverner et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis tel aviv avec aulas
lier journalistes pour rt internationale
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
bonsoir paula slayer merci beaucoup
d'être en direct sur rt france bayemi
netanyahu a jusqu'à minuit donc un pour
former un gouvernement encore deux
heures et 13 minutes précisément faute
de quoi il devrait devenir chef de
l'opposition ce soir quelles sont les
options
ce stage personne ne comprend pas par sa
motion ce qui va arriver
les options pour le premier ministre
sont de rendre le mandat au président
henri blin et c'est sans doute ce qu'il
va faire mais la question est que va
faire le président avec son mandat
va-t-il le donnait à la pizza le chef de
l'opposition et le second est candidat
pour devenir premier ministre mais le
transfert at il à nathalie bellec qui
est numéro trois dans la ligne de
succession et retournera-t-il le mandat
au parlement si le président et rend le
mandat au parlement ils sont deux
options
ils peuvent décider d'organiser il
s'inquiète un cinquième scrutin où ils
peuvent demander un scrutin direct pour
le premier ministre du pays à ce stage
après on ne sait pas ce que le président
va décider de faire ce qui est clair
c'est que benyamin nétanyahou n'a pas
réussi à former un gouvernement
alors effectivement comme l'appui de ses
ailiers un des partis juifs
ultra-orthodoxes n'est pas suffisant le
premier ministre a multiplié les
contacts ces dernières semaines dans
l'espoir d'atteindre ce seuil
vous le dites 1 pour l'instant en vain
comment expliquez-vous paula le refus de
tous les leaders politiques à ses
multiples tentatives et gestes tendu
inzaghi politique habile et que chaque
dirigeant politique à son programme
spécifique et il y a tant de partis
politiques qui doivent se réunir si on
peut espérer une majorité de 61 sièges
par exemple des questions de religion et
d'état m'ont fait des repas divisek
arrêté par thiriez ont-ils netanyahu
sont divergent sur ce point par exemple
le camp anti natanyahou et fédérer sous
une même bannière
car ils considèrent que cela fait trop
longtemps le cas merci les difficultés
comme vous le savez un procès approche
et pour eux ce procès fait à israël
il devait s'agir d'ailleurs d'un très
bien procès contre le premier ministre
il ya également parfois une forme de
vendetta personnelle contre le ministre
cela n'est pas suffisant
empêcher les divisions internes des
partis
par exemple il habite une le dirigeant à
bord et l'opposition conseil de
rassembler des partis d'extrême droite
et d'extrême gauche lo se mettront
jamais d'accord sur un grand nombre de
sujets à part leur détestation de
netanyahu alors si le premier ministre
est chou ce qui semble probable en tout
cas cette heure-ci sauf surprise il faut
dire qu'une page se tourne pour l'état
hébreu la première fois depuis 12 ans
comment réagissent les israéliens c'est
pas rien
le minisre alliant benyamin nétanyahou a
eu la longévité la plus longue depuis la
création du pays devait organiser des
sondages en ce moment même dans les rues
d'israël sinon demandez aux gens qui
voudraient avoir comme premier ministre
environ 80 pour son camp israélien
soutiendrai encore netanyahu et 20% le
dirigeant de l'opposition ils appellent
notamment à droite qu'un pays la
majorité du pays
il y aura beaucoup de tristesse et de
déception si benjamin netanyahu se
retire peu probable qu'ils deviennent
dirigeants de l'opposition pour le
moment car personne le pourrait former
une majorité parlementaire
j'ai parlé avec air lapide dirigeants de
l'opposition et il ne peut obtenir qu
environ 50 des 61 sièges requis pour le
moment il est difficile de croire qu'il
pourrait y avoir bientôt un premier
ministre en israël
mais il est certain que la plupart des
israéliens seront déçus si le prochain
premier ministre n'est pas benyamin
nétanyahou a bola il deviendra alors
chef de l'opposition
quel type de chefs d'opposition
sera-t-il selon vous
je ne pense pas qu'il serait isolé dans
l'opposition car il aura le soutien des
partis religieux de tous les partis de
droite
il n'aura pas une majorité des soutiens
ce qui explique effectivement qu'il va
se retrouver dans l'opposition plutôt
qu'au poste de premier ministre mais
comme je le dis pour le moment personne
d'autre ne peut former de coalition donc
il est difficile de parler pour
l'élément d'opposition je souhaite
également à souligner le fait que le
système politique israélien est
complètement fracture et nous en sommes
à cinq élections en l'espace de deux ans
et l'atmosphère en israël est une
atmosphère bâti les israéliens sont las
des élections ils ont assez de se rendre
aux urnes
après ça arrive line propose d'ailleurs
la petite de forme un gouvernement
cela repousserait encore eu tout le
processus et le ferait que renforcer la
frustration au sein de la population
israélienne
il faut également savoir que cela coûte
beaucoup d'argent à l'économie
israélienne
et cela renforce encore les frustrations
donc il y à beaucoup de tensions dans
les rues beaucoup d'appétit démocrate
est une autre question un susciter et
s'il y avait un autre élection quel
serait le taux de participation les
israéliens en majorité en entassés de
ces élections à ces centres qui ne
produisent aucun résultat réponse en
tout cas concernant benyamin nétanyahou
d'un peu plus de deux heures merci
beaucoup pour la slayer jeunesse portée
internationale d'avoir été avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons la liberté de la presse
au lendemain de la journée mondiale qui
lui est consacré est tellement
c'est en france ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face et puis nous irons en
espagne jour de vote à madrid un scrutin
pour élire l'assemblée de la région
étape décisive pour la droite espagnole
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
la dictée pour tous que se rapporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à la dgre au poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse avec
difficile
[Musique]
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pj les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station billard ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplôme ès on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans bienvenue à novossibirsk heures
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois celle en profiter en 2011
le monde manque pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire de la plongée autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur un terreau ans
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 4 mai les républicains apportent
leur soutien à renaud muselier en
l'absence d'accord avec la reine dans la
région paca c'est la réponse il ya
quelques instants du parti à l'issue
d'une réunion du comité d'investiture
elle fait suite au communiqué cet après
midi du président sortant affichant
clairement sa position il n'y aura pas
d'accord avec en marche
côté gouvernement gabriela talent
affirme lui qu'il y aura bien sûr des
candidats la reine sur la lys de renaud
muselier
on sera en direct dans quelques instants
avec estelle farges une forte
dégradation des relations entre
journalistes et forces de l'ordre c'est
la conclusion du rapport commandé par le
gouvernement est remis hier à jean
castex
une tension qui s'observe notamment lors
des manifestations que l'adoption de la
loi sécurité globale n'a fait que
détériorer au lendemain de la journée
mondiale de la liberté de la presse on
s'interroge est elle menacée en france
les tells davantage encore en temps de
pandémie ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face
jour de vote en espagne + 2 5 millions
d'électeurs appelés à élire l'assemblée
de la région mais dry dans ce [ __ ]
portée nationale la droite favorite
espère un retour aux affaires alors que
le parti socialiste du premier ministre
sanchez pourrait suivi un être qu il
d'après les sondages
l'espagne qui prévoit de lever l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à partir du 9 mai et
sauver sa saison touristique
le g7 cherche un front commun face à la
chine réunion à londres des ministres
des affaires étrangères des sept pays ce
mardi objectif ressouder les alliances
pour faire respecter un ordre mondial
fondé selon les règles instaurées par
ces pays une volonté réaffirmée par le
chef de la diplomatie américaine anthony
blinken
[Musique]
les directions tout de suite le siège
des républicains dans le 15e
arrondissement à paris le parti de
droite en ébullition vous savez depuis
deux jours après l annonce de jean
castex du retrait de la liste la reine
dans la région paca au profit des listes
lr et ce soir il y à du nouveau après un
comité d'investiture estelle farges
vous êtes en direct sur place quels sont
les tout derniers développements
et bien stéphanie rpt le parti à l'est
républicain apporte son soutien à
renault amusé ollier en l'absence
d'accord avec la république en marche
déclarations de christian jacob à
l'issue de la commission d'investiture
qui sait qui c'est tenu ici ce soir je
vous propose d'écouter le patron des
républicains
c'est un accord d'une famille rassemblée
qui a été secoué
mais rassembler aujourd'hui avec renaud
muselier et les républicains qui sortent
renforcés de cette de cette ceni puisque
l'accord est quasi quasi unanime à
quelques voix près la république en
marche a démontré sa faiblesse la
faiblesse on la connaît ils sont
incapables de constituer une liste
incapables de porter un projet
alternatif uniquement capables de
manoeuvre et de nuisances et le premier
ministre a été clairement renvoyé dans
ses cordes
après les déclarations qu'il avait pu
faire dimanche dernier donc c'est une
belle victoire mais surtout ça nous met
en situation de gagner les régionales
est ce qui était déterminant pour
qu est déterminant pour nous renaud
muselier et sa majorité bénéficie d'un
bilan remarquable
il est souligné par tous voilà pour ce
tacle envers la république en marche
christian jacob l'avait déjà exprimé un
petit peu plus tôt un brouillage traduit
pour lui l incapacité pour la république
en marche de conduire une liste dans la
région paca du côté des drm et bien
gabriel attal affirme ce soir qu'il y
aura bien sûr des candidats lrm sur la
liste de renaud muselier mais christian
jacob a été très clair pas de
parlementaires a pas de ministre je vous
rappelle que tout ce remue ménage est
partie de l' annonce de jean castex 1 ce
dimanche le premier ministre qui avait
fait part du retrait de la liste elle l
om dans la région au profit à 2 7 de
celle conduite par renaud muselier le
principal intéressé qui là aussi en ré
affirmé adam un comité comme unique et à
la mi journée il n'y a pas et il n'y
aura pas d'accord à quelques niveaux que
ce soit avec en marche pas plus qu'avec
d'autres appareils fin de citation
merci sf argent ni règle du siège des
républicains
au lendemain de la journée
internationale de la liberté de la
presse un rapport remis à matignon
évoque une forte dégradation entre
reporter et forces de l'ordre alors que
le dernier classement de rsf place un
pari au 34e rang du classement mondial
de la liberté de la presse thomas bonnet
pour les explications pour la journée
mondiale de la liberté de la presse le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a publié ce tweet volontariste
les journalistes nous informent écrit le
locataire de l'élysée continuerons à
nous battre pour qu'ils restent libres
partout dans le monde
continuons à nous battre pour les
protéger continuons à nous battre contre
la désinformation qui menacent nos
démocraties pour la paix la justice les
droits humains un message rapidement
contestée par des internautes qui font
remarquer au président français que la
liberté de la presse est menacée
y compris dans son pays notamment depuis
son élection en 2017
et il est vrai que si emmanuel macron
souhaite protéger les journalistes
on pourrait commencer par ceux qui
travaillent en france en pointant à la
34e place du classement de l'omg
reporters sans frontières l'hexagone
reste coincé à une place qu'il occupe
depuis plusieurs années déjà
lo ng exprime notamment ses inquiétudes
concernant les interpellations de
journalistes
des faits qui se sont produits ces
derniers mois souvent dans le cadre de
manifestations une relation entre les
forces de l'ordre et les journalistes
déjà compliquée que l'adoption de la loi
sécurité globale n'a fait que détériorer
le fameux article 24 visant à protéger
les forces de l'ordre contre la
diffusion de leur identité a créé un
flou législatif sur la possibilité de
filmer les policiers et les gendarmes
c'est dans ce contexte qu'un rapport a
été remis au premier ministre
rédigé par une commission indépendante
il formule 32 propositions pour tenter
de corriger cette dégradation des
relations entre les deux professions
s'agissant de la possibilité de les
filmer le rapport propose je cite de
rappeler clairement aux forces de
l'ordre qu'elles ne peuvent en principe
se posait à la captation d'image ou deux
des opérations qu'il mène dans les lieux
publics ni a fortiori demandé la
suppression de tels enregistrements
reste à voir maintenant ce que matignon
fera de ces propositions toujours est il
que les alertes de la part des ong
telles qu'amnesty international ou
d'institutions comme le conseil de
l'europe se multiplient à l'égard de la
france
ce dernier demandant encore tout
récemment des actions concrètes de la
part des gouvernements européens pour
garantir la sécurité des journalistes le
plus grand nombre d'atteintes à
l'intégrité physique des journalistes a
été signalé dans la fédération de russie
en italie et au royaume uni la france la
pologne la turquie et l'ukraine compte
pour l'heure par le plus grand nombre de
cas d'intimidation et de harcèlement de
journalistes
et si ces méfaits précède pour beaucoup
le mandat des modèles macron ce dernier
n'est pas beaucoup agi pour garantir la
liberté d'informer l'ancien ministre de
l'économie entretient une relation pour
le moins particulière avec les
journalistes
observateur avisé du paysage médiatique
il a toutefois fait apparaître une forme
de distance quasiment du mépris pour les
journalistes
et puis comment ne pas rappeler que
l'actuel locataire de l'elysée a décidé
de ne pas accepter les journalistes de
notre média au sein du palais
présidentiel
rt france persona non grata lors des
conférences de presse de l'elysée tout
comme lors des meetings de campagne de
la république en marche
si on résume pourrait mener le macron
défendre les journalistes
oui mais seulement ceux qu'il a choisis
alors au lendemain de la journée
mondiale de la liberté de la presse on
s'interroge les journalistes sont-ils
vraiment libre en france la liberté de
la presse est elle davantage mener c'est
encore en temps de pandémie
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en débattre mathieu
hutin rédacteur en chef de la radio h 20
dans les alpes
vous êtes arrivé
vous arrivez une drôle de mésaventure
récemment m fulup impute un pardon on va
en parler dans quelques instants à vos
côtés alexandre langlois secrétaire
général du syndicat policier vigie
bonsoir à vous aussi alexandre langlois
merci d'être avec nous continuons à nous
battre pour qu'ils restent libres
continuons à nous battre contre la
désinformation qui menacent nos
démocraties cette petite phrase est
signée emmanuel macron et elle a piqué
pas mal de journalistes avant de vous
faire réagir je voudrais vous faire
écouter l'un d'entre eux en tant que
journaliste je trouve ces propos
indécents quand on a fait passer les
lois les plus liberticides de ces
dernières décennies et qu'on s'applique
chaque jour à essayer de bâillonner la
presse indépendante
la moindre des choses c'est de nous
épargner cette tirade dans cette
journaliste pas vraiment contente vous
mathieu [ __ ] comment vous analysé
cette sortie du président l'a pressé et
libre comme on l'imaginé où il y a des
doutes aujourd'hui
bonsoir c'est fanny de muri bonsoir
alexandre langlois la radio s'appelle
h2o juste au passage comment j'analyse
7,8 du chef de l'état si je voulais être
acide mais je vais l'être
je dirais que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions on ne peut pas faire preuve
de deux dossiers bonnes intentions dans
la mesure où il ya cet article 24 il ya
cette loi de sécurité global extrêmement
contestée et cristallise et qui
cristallise les relations entre les
forces d'ordre et les journalistes alors
qu'elle ne l'était pas et vous avez
parlé de ce rapport il ya quelques
minutes dans un sujet ce rapport il dit
que c'est remonte cinq ans en arrière
les relations entre les journalistes et
les forces de l'ordre
elle était bonne comment on en est
arrivé là j'espère qu'on va pouvoir en
parler qu'alexandre l'emploi alors
justement alexandre loi et pardon pour
évidemment la coquille sur sur votre
radio h2o pour le quel regard porte le
policier sur cette question est-ce que
clairement
journalistes faire leur boulot en france
sans pression vous qui avez l'habitude
du terrain alexandre langlois bonsoir
bonsoir votre invité non il ya une
répression y la police est même utilisé
pour justement mettre la pression aux
journalistes donc évidemment ce qu'on
voit sur le terrain avec la sécurité et
loi globale
la loi est faite pour mettre pression
sur les journalistes parce que des lois
protègent déjà les policiers mieux que
ce que prévoit cette cette loi on a une
connexion versailles qui a été filmé par
des captations d'image pour lui nuire la
personne qui a fait ça + 17 mois de
prison ferme sans la loi la deuxième
chose on a aussi le nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre en septembre dernier
qui dit que battant les journalistes
devront souvent est accréditée par le
ministre de l'intérieur où la préfecture
pour pouvoir suivre des manifestations
et si on leur demande de se disperser
donc moment où l'information peut être
intéressant qu'ils devront se soumettre
aux injonctions et puis pour finir on a
pu voir toute ces derniers temps la
teinte aussi à aux sources des
journalistes
on a eu des perquisitions des tentatives
de perquisitions chez médiapart dans la
sphère benalla nous avons des
journalistes convoqué la dg ici le
journaliste du monde dans l'affairé
mediapart des journalistes plus
indépendant sur les armes de la france
au yémen
nous avons eu encore récemment dans la
sphère samuel pâti des journalistes de
libération qui sont cette fois ci passer
à l'igpn
donc nous voyons bien que la police ait
complètement détournée de ses missions
pour protéger l'état et ça pose un
sérieux problème sur l'indépendance des
journalistes en france alors mathieu
hutin vous par exemple vous avez été
poursuivis récemment pour avoir couvert
une manifestation sur le tarmac un
aéroport dance et je le disais en début
et au tribunal vous vous êtes étonné
bien des arguments du ministère public
qui vous a comparé à des militants
racontez nous oui effectivement on a été
assimilée dans la procédure à des
militants parce qu'au tout début de de
cette manifestation tout s'est
extrêmement bien passé on a seize
minutes d'une manifestation pacifiste
avec 15 militants d'extinction robes à
lyon une intervention des forces de
l'ordre que nous on connaît parce qu'on
fait de la police justice sur le terrain
nous on est dans une petite ville de
province donc tout le monde se connaît
les forces de l'ordre savent qui on est
et puis elles arrivent elles sont 2 au
début un des deux gendarmes qui arrive
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport les
militants et la presse allez allez
quitter le lieu de la manifestation
et puis ça fige ça fige les deux
journalistes disent personne ne bouge
et puis finalement
on voit une voiture de voitures trois
voitures et à la fin au bout d'une
demi-heure tout de même les les
gendarmes sont plus nombreux que les
manifestants
on évacue tout le monde dans le calme ça
se passe super bien en ce cas les
militants de d'ixair sont pacifistes
puis nous on n'avait pas non plus de
raison de se rebeller même si on
s'étonne mais on nous le dit en catimini
comme on nous le dit à la faim en
sortant du tarmac bas les journalistes
vous allez venir aussi vous expliquer la
gendarmerie et puis à la gendarmerie
bon on fait un peu pression sur nous
pour qu'on explique comment on savait
qu'il y avait une manifestation ce qui
est pas tolérable mais ça peut être
compris comme de de la maladresse en
tout cas moi aujourd'hui formellement je
ne sais pas s'il y avait un ordre de
nous faire parler sur ça aussi c'est une
simple maladresse de gendarmes puis moi
je veux accuser personne parce qu'on a
des bonnes relations avec les gendarmes
ici et puis les gendarmes nous disent
bon bah finalement vous serez sortie de
la procédure
sauf qu'on se retrouve convoquée au
tribunal de police à devoir s'expliquer
et à devoir dire non non nous étions un
journaliste est le motif pour lequel
nous étions là et est valable si on
prend le rapport la liste de
recommandations parce que c'est quand
même intéressant on a mis des magistrats
on a mis des policiers on a mis des gens
de la presse autour d'une table ça s'est
passé au ministère de l'intérieur sous
la présidence de jean marie delarue qui
conseiller d'état et on sort 32
propositions la liste des
recommandations a été faite hier et dans
l'est dans les recommandations
c'est clair et c'est net on doit pouvoir
couvrir des manifestations même si elles
sont illégales ou non déclarés c'est
curieux quand même alexandra quand vous
écoutez ce témoignage ça vous évoque
quoi vous vous déplorez j'imagine ces
relations qui sont peut-être plus tendue
qu'avant la faute à quoi à qui s'est
notamment le contexte de la loi c'est
que global qui étend les choses vous
disiez tout à l'heure ça m'a interpellé
on se sert de la police contre les
manifestants qui cesseront non c'est lui
le gouvernement le ronge et réclamant le
gouvernement les politiques ce car les
ordres viennent du ministère de
l'intérieur la préfecture de police qui
sont les préfets sont des personnes
nommées par les politiques les grands
directeurs de la police qui ont peur
pour leur poste ou qui cherchent des
avancements dans les départements donc
c'est contre les manifestants oui on
utilisa police mais contre la presse
également parce qu'en fait on a ce
gouvernement plutôt que d'avoir une
police républicaine est propre dans ses
actions ou alors dans les gens qui
veulent manifester en face d'eux en fait
ils préfèrent cacher et mettre la
poussière sous le tapis
il ya aussi eu un rapport aussi de l'onu
sur la loi sécurité globale qui dénonce
ce qui se passe également en france sur
la liberté de la presse
on n'est pas non plus très bien classé
dans la liberté de la presse mondiale
34e donc il ya plein de choses qui sont
inquiétantes et ça pose des problèmes
parce que les services de police on
travaille en général en bonne
intelligence avec la presse
parce que ça permet des fois de prévenir
certaines actions de passer encadrer
correctement les gens fassent leur
travail dont en bonne intelligence moi
je sais que pour avoir travaillé sur
terrain régulièrement avec la presse
autant que renvoie aux renseignements
intériste orial à chaque fois pour
éviter le comptage selon la police selon
la presse sont les manifestants réunis
c'est tout le monde ont compté ensemble
et ça se déroulait dans une ambiance bon
enfant chacun est utile à tout le monde
et à partir de là on arrive à une
volonté du pouvoir en fait de cacher
tout ce qui va contre lui et donc là on
est sur quelque chose d'une dérive qui
pose de nombreux problèmes et après la
censure continue également au delà de la
police on a eu des lois anti fait que 12
qui décide qui fait l'affectueuse il ya
des censures qu'arrive à tel point que
c'est tellement ridicule que même le
gouvernement s'était fait censuré
pendant parler des européennes par
twitter donc on voit bien que les lois
sont tellement mal ficelé qu'on sait
plus qui a le droit de dire quoi qu'ils
aient droit de couvrir quoi donc ça pose
un sérieux problème de sur la liberté
d'information et la liberté
d'information est nécessaire et en fait
toutes ces lois crise que des relations
qui étaient bien et en fait on crée des
problèmes où il n'y en avait pas avant
mathieu est un vous avez ce même
diagnostic le gouvernement aimerait bien
donner peut-être une bonne image est
caché un petit peu ce qui va pas dans
son sens c'est aussi votre avis sur le
terrain vous vous partagez
moi j'ai pas constaté ça parce que enfin
j'ai pas de preuve factuelle pour vous
l'affirmer comme le dit alexandre
langlois qui est policier et et il ne
pourra enfin personne pour mieux le dire
que lui par contre qui d'autre aurait
intérêt effectivement à ce que ça se
passe de cette façon là moi je vous le
redis que les personnes de terrain les
gendarmes les policiers que nous
côtoyons sur les manifestations
tout se passe bien sauf quand il ya ce
dérapage avec des gendarmes qui nous
disent en off bas on avait ordre d'être
plus nombreux que vous à la fin de la
manifestation
donc effectivement allons plus loin est
ce qu'ils ont eu ordre également de nous
poursuivre par la suite moi je voudrais
juste relater ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end samedi sur la manifestation du
1er mai avec un tweet de commissaire de
police
et si cp qui nous dit ils n'ont plus
peur de rien en plein jour dans la
manifestation policier violemment
agressé par un voyou
sous l'oeil des caméras et des témoins
seuls les policiers lui porteront
secours le spectacle visiblement doit
primer moi je m'inquiète je crois qu'on
arrive proche du jour où on va nous dire
mais messieurs dames les journalistes il
ya de la violence c'est parce qu'il ya
des caméras vous êtes là donc ça incite
les gens à dépasser la borne qui nous
disent ah là c'est un syndicat de
commissaires de police
est ce que réellement on essaye de nous
monter les uns contre les autres les
policiers les gendarmes contre les
journalistes
sous prétexte que ce serait nous qui
attise aurions les motifs de
manifestations et la violence dans les
manifestations
moi je m'inquiète vraiment de ça et je
suis ravi de pouvoir aller échanger avec
alexandre hollan gloire qui semble être
un policier sens et de terrain et qui a
constaté comme moi qu'on pouvait se
parler sur le terrain sur une
manifestation et chacun faire son
travail son problème draria un autre
aspect je voulais vous faire entendre
celui évoqué par le grand reporter
fondateur de la plateforme média et
démocratie olivier pineau écouter ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir ont globalement
saisi le prétexte de la crise ducobu de
10,9 pour accentuer leur volonté de
maîtrise des médias
alors ça y va franco a c'est un prétexte
cette crise sanitaire pour accentuer la
volonté de maîtrise des médias alexandre
langlois c'est un petit peu votre
sentiment également sur le terrain
évidemment ça va même dans le sens même
le secrétaire général de l'onu a fait un
rapport dans ce sens là donc on est
vraiment dans un contrôle des médias il
ya même le journal anglais the economist
avait déclassé la france en démocratie
défaillante suite à sa gestion de la
crise qu vide donc il ya vraiment un
problème qui fait qu'on veut cacher les
choses on ne veut pas faire les choses
et on voit bien qu'on est dans la
communication qu'on est capable par
exemple de déployé des milliers de
policiers pour vérifier des attestations
et par contre pour lutter contre le
trafic de drogue on met un numéro vert
en place à tel point que même des gens
comme le préfet de police de marseille
qui depuis a été remercié pour ses bons
et loyaux services avait déclaré que
c'était un problème sur les attestations
y avec les dealers qui les avait pas
alors que six aprem de santé publique
vente de la drogue est quand même un
petit peu plus grave qu'une attestation
donc ça se contrôle set m'a mise on ne
veut pas que quelque chose sorte se
contrôler effectivement de un petit peu
partout et je donne un exemple a été
sorti le budget par exemple de l'elysée
pour contrôler sa réputation sur les
réseaux sociaux est supérieur au budget
pour le forum de la laïcité présidée par
marlène schiappa donc on voit bien
l'ordre de priorité c'est qu'on est sur
une guerre de l'image une guerre de la
presse et on venait plus du tout sur
fond de là on est sûr de la propagande
techniquement il y avait un autre
exemple qui avait été assez marquant
c'était la ferme et chase est clair on a
eu des images donc de violences
policières et du coup la réponse de
monsieur darmana a été quelques semaines
après deux films et un policier lors
d'une manifestation qui se fait défoncer
la mâchoire et on est quasiment
persuadés comme une unité en main cas de
l'or ne peut agir que sur ans et que
soit ils ont été mal commandé ça c'est
un fait mais ce qu'ils n'ont pas été mal
commandé exprès pour faire des images
donc on est sur une guerre image contre
images le fait que nous conte fait que
youssoupha on est sur quelque chose de
complètement aberrant il serait temps de
remettre la vérité l'information et que
les gens puissent se forger leur opinion
ce que le jour où il n'y a plus de place
libre les gens que ce pur se forger une
opinion et on peut les manipuler
alors on lisait un rapport un énième
peut-être pour être taquin commandé par
le gouvernement en décembre dernier a
été remis hier au premier ministre avec
32 propositions on regardait ce
communiqué de matignon
le rapport argumenté équilibrée permet
au gouvernement de travailler à établir
une relation plus sereine et un cadre de
dialogue renforcé entre la presse et les
forces de l'ordre
un comité de suivi sera installée à cet
effet dans les prochains jours il sera
décliné au plan local par des instances
de dialogue permettant de partager les
contraintes propres à chaque métier
alors c'est vrai mais dessus usa on est
spécialiste des rapports avant dans ce
pays on ne les compte plus alors par
exemple lors celui-ci propose parmi les
32 propositions donc de permettre aux
journalistes de se placer derrière les
cordons des forces de l'ordre pour
garantir leur sécurité physique
c'est ce genre de mesure vers lesquels
il faut aller non je crois pas pas du
tout effectivement les forces de l'ordre
doivent assurer la sécurité des
journalistes présents sur une
manifestation
mais la couverture d'une manifestation
elle est totale ou alors elle ne l'est
pas ça veut quand même dire une chose ça
veut dire qu'en fait on aura le droit de
filmer de faire notre travail à un
certain endroit de la manifestation moi
je crois pas que
aujourd'hui quand on va couvrir une
manifestation on doit nous restreindre
le
lieu où on doit filmer ou rapporter ce
qui s'est passé à un endroit de la
manifestation quand les cortèges sont
immenses il peut se passer énormément de
choses dans dans les cortèges
non non moi je je je pense que c'est une
dérive
le rapport recommande également je suis
clairement aux forces de l'ordre
de quelles peuvent en principe s'opposer
à la captation d'image ou de sons des
opérations menées dans des lieux publics
alexandre l'angoissent ça vous inspire
quoi toutes ces propositions que c'est
comme depuis que les manceaux qu'on veut
pas régler un problème on réunit deux
commissions on demande de réunir ces
propositions des recommandations qui ne
seront pas appliquées on a pu voir ce
qui s'est passé sur la convention sur le
climat at on toujours des résultats
par contre qu'est ce que ça inspire
s'inspire qu'un amalgame un mélange des
genres et en os non parce que
effectivement les certaines opérations
de police qui disent ici que la
discrétion ces démissions secret défense
des jets et 6 contre terrorisme police
judiciaire sur certaines interpellations
et en fait ce gouvernement a l'art de
tout mélanger et ça effectivement il ya
des missions qui doivent être protégés
mais le maintien de l'ordre d'émission
quotidienne sur le terrain les
conditions de la police veut dire
quotidienne n'y a pas de raison de
paniquer quand on est en train de mettre
des situations compliquées au nom de
beauté sur des pistes qui n'est pas vrai
déjà protégés existants encore
faudrait-il qu'ils soient appliqués mais
là une fois de plus ya pas de volonté du
gouvernement les applique
et on est vraiment sûr de la propagande
de la chine ont fait discuter des gens
on oppose les personnes et pendant qu'on
discute de tous ces sujets là pas par
exemple c'est parce qu'on travaille sur
deux sujets à couvrir une en train de se
battre pour justement la presse m [ __ ]
le mot de la fin pour vous si vous
deviez justement vous si vous êtes des
dut participer à ce rapport qu'auriez
vous proposez qu'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui clairement pardon je vais
répondre à côté stéphanie de murs rue
mais je crois que j'ai pas lu le même
rapport recommandation numéro 3 rappeler
clairement aux forces de l'ordre
qu'elles ne peuvent en principe
s'opposer à la captation d'image ou de
sons des opérations qu'il mène dans les
lieux publics que celle ci soit le fait
de journalistes ou de toute autre
personne
je crois qu'il ya quand même des bonnes
choses dans ce rapport je ne veux pas
voir tout blanc ou tout noir
il faut continuer de défendre cette
liberté de la presse veiller au grain il
faudra toujours le faire mais je crois
qu'on s'est mal compris sur cette
recommandation numéro trois un mot
peut-être
lexandre langlois et de réponse ces
terres que cette recommandation en fête
existe déjà dans la loi donc en fait on
est en train d'enfoncer des portes
s'ouvriront aucune fois de plus eu
appliquons la loi ce qui ne fait pas ce
gouvernement ce qui est assez dramatique
et je repenserai toujours à un sondage
qui avait été fait près de dix mille
policiers qu'est ce que vous demanderiez
en premier ministre a tort si vous
pouviez changer qu'une chose la réponse
a été à 70% que le ministère de
l'intérieur respecte la loi
donc voilà on en est là on est en train
de faire des recommandations tout ça
mais appliquant ce qui existe on aura
déjà réglé beaucoup de choses merci en
tout cas à tous les deux mais tu est un
rédacteur en chef
h 2 o 1 radio et non pas lâchement radio
merci à vous également
langlois d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
face à face et dans quelques instants
rester avec nous parlerons de l'élection
régionale à madrid un scrutin a rapporté
nationale mais aussi de la situation
sanitaire dans le pays puis direction
londres où les ministres des affaires
étrangères sont réunis dans le cadre du
g20
[Musique]
mais en fait mine ici des commis tous
les deux à trois jours en france
actuellement pourquoi il shoote au
encore à protéger totalement les femmes
on dit souvent aux femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'ils
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui révèle il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'ya pas interactive on sort du
pays il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
vous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change l'équilibré
stratégique pour le moyen-orient après
50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette région
complexe tron était le seul à pouvoir
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
grâce à ses relations différentes avec
tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
bâle
[Musique]
28 d'entre eux ont souhaité bienvenue en
direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez en espagne la région de madrid
votent aujourd'hui pour renouveler son
assemblée élire son nouveau président
est la droite espagnole favorite dans un
fief qu'elle dirige depuis plus de 25
ans voit en ces élections régionales un
tremplin pour la reconquête du pouvoir
au niveau national une campagne tendue
avec en filigrane la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le premier ministre
socialiste pedro sanchez son parti
pourrait enregistrer son pire résultat
dans la région la plus riche d'espagne
et la plus importante politiquement et
la crise sanitaire en espagne toujours
le pays prolonge jusqu'au 25 mai les
restrictions sur les arrivées du brésil
et d'afrique du sud l'espagne qui
devrait mettre fin à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le 9 mai cette région envisage
de maintenir un confinement nocturne
pour sortir de la crise deux pays s'est
fixé des objectifs ambitieux côté
vaccination avec 70 % des espagnols
vacciner d'ici à la fin du mois d'août
la commission européenne qui se félicite
de l' accélération de la campagne plus
d'un quart de la population de l'ue
on a reçu au moins une dose et pour en
parler nous sommes avec erwan ambrosio
ni médecin infectiologue à l'hôpital
clinic de barcelone vont soir un homme
aux yeux ni merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors prolongation
à des restrictions sur les arrivées du
brésil et d'afrique du sud
pour vous en espagne plus que nécessaire
au mieux vaut tard que jamais selon vous
alors je pense que ça risque quand même
nécessaire pose pas vraiment de garder
cette direction pour certains souche qui
passe il coulait qui pourrait peut-être
pas complètement protégées par les
vaccins kahn actuellement je pense que
pour le moment ça reste quelque chose de
plus prudent est ce que c'est déjà trop
tard pour le moment il n'y a pas de ce
type de variants présents sur le
territoire espagnol n'est pas nommément
alors les on a eu très peu de
circulation pour le moment je pense que
c'est encore un bon moment pour tous le
calvez sont en restriction éviter que ça
soit dit seigner d'une façon très lâche
alors évidemment vous vous êtes en
première ligne depuis des mois dans
l'unité qu'ovide à l'hospital clinic de
barcelone
comment qualifier la situation sanitaire
actuelle
alors c'est vrai que moi je peux parler
de la situation en catalogne qui n'est
pas forcément la même dans tous les pays
puisqu'ils avec l'indifférence à nos
différentes communautés autonomes mais
c'est vrai que même si on avait peur de
la dénomination des cas après après
pâques ce n'était pas le cas
en tout cas un cas travailler la moue
l'hôpital donc on reste situation quand
même qui était ce pour le moment mais
mais qui a pas énormément et je les
appelais après pâques n'ont pour le
moment la situation n'est pas si mauvais
qu'on attendait donc la levée possible
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 9 mai
ça vous semble plutôt raisonnable vous
êtes pour en tant qu infectiologues
alors je pense que c'est grâce au niveau
national mais après c'est ça dépend des
siens communiqué autonome de faire les
messieurs qui sont de plus adéquat pour
la situation déprimée logique locale
c'est à dire on ne sait pas très bien
encore ce qui va se passer en catalan
sait qu'ils vont quelle va être la
décision d'aider son autorité catalan
pour la continuation après les semaines
mais c'est qu'il y avait certains
régions dans les pays en espagne et où
c'est clair qu'il va falloir continuer
avec des restrictions très important
parce qu'il est très tôt ses missions
ses précédents et encore je pense que
c'est rationnel déterminer le cette
situation s'était tendue aux chances au
niveau du pays
mais c'est quand même très important de
prendre les mesures adéquates dans
chaque communauté autonome par rapport à
la situation locale
alors on espère plus de 25% de la
population devrait être vaccinée pour
lever justement ces conditions ça vous
semble assez 25% de la population
je pense que c'est un peu seul quand
même j'aime aller un peu plus mais ça
valait calais on est maintenant très
près de l'été il faut chercher une
situation où on puisse ne pas pénaliser
trop les côtes l'économique et le
tourisme donc je pense que c'est
maintenant le moment pour l'accélérer la
remontée un peu cette proportion de la
population qui est vacciné que la liga 5
millions de personnes qui avaient
complété le schéma de vaccination mais
moi je pense que c'est encore trop
faible je pense qu'il faut vraiment des
lamantins pour l'été tranquille face de
vous il était bon le voit on a quelques
petits problèmes avec le vaccin trois
aînés cas en france et beaucoup de
réticence cela s'ajoute la pénurie uns
des autres vexant pour le moment est ce
que c'est la même situation en espagne
oui c'est pas là et je pense que c'est
la situation partout parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de l'information qui n'était
pas correcte la dissémination de
l'information n'a pas trouvé la
situation sanitaire
je pense qu'il y assez fait scandale qui
sont claires les sons graves qui sont
très très rares
on n'a peut-être pas eu assé sécurité
par rapport au message qui ont dressé
les autorités ont je pense que cette
citation de la population c'est pas
quelque chose très bon
mais aussi on n'a pas encore une
décision très claire et sans autorité
quoi faire avec les jeunes qui a reçu
les chars la première bosse comme on va
continuer à vacciner tous ces gens je
pense que c'était des citations ne sont
pas très bon pour le message surnom de
sécurité puis les autorités pour la
population alors y est un concept et un
chez vous à barcelone de 5000 personnes
menée fin mars sans distance mais avec
masques a priori aucun signe de
contagion aux kovy détecter un mois
après vous vous attendiez à un tel
résultat comment comment on peut
d'ailleurs se l'expliquer alors je crois
que c'est très beau mais c'était une
populace entre les sélectionneurs parce
qu'il savait fédérer sert avant tout les
antigènes m'écoutais je sais pas si
c'est la solution mais c'est quand même
peut-être une façon d'avancer vers une
certaine normalité qui nous manque à
tous
je pense que c'est une très bonne
expérience par ailleurs chantal j'ai vu
que j'ai lu que un angle atterrissent à
leur répéter ça avec d'autres concerts
aussi je pense qu'ils ont l'expérience
mais pour le moment il faut rester
prudent avec les résultats parce que
c'est une expérience pilote on peut pas
les généralistes pour le moment on
entendait sur une chaîne française le
pdg de modern à nous dire hier que le
virus selon lui en tout cas ne
disparaîtrait pas et qu'il faudrait
désormais vivre avec être vaccinés
chaque année comme la grippe est ce que
vous en tant qu infectiologues vous
partagez cet avis tout à fait je veux
pas les connaissances biologiques
peut-être nécessaire pour me prononcer
d'une façon ça me troue censure je pense
que ça va être la citation moins que ça
va continuer à circuler et à mon avis il
va avoir les issers quand ils collation
des souches pour lesquels on sait là pas
forcément complètement protégé
effectivement je sais pas si la
publicité ça va être tous les sens il va
falloir faire les vaccinations régulier
je suis d'accord alors vous allez
peut-être mieux lotis en espagne
puisqu'il ya le laboratoire ils prat qui
est en train de fabriquer un
un vaccin on imagine qu'il est très
attendu un vaccin donc 100% espagnole
ouais effectivement je pense que c'est
quelque chose de plus important des
comptes avec un accent de plus mais
finalement je pense que c'est pas si
important qui va produire les vaccins
mais d'avoir assez de doses pour tout le
monde c'est ça qui est le plus important
espérons que ça va être avec une autre
fille qu'à citer une provocation de
l'anticorps accéléré je pense qu'ici les
plus importants sont maintenant assez
d'armes entre la pression des
populations qui vacciner l'emportent
avec quel vaccin évidemment il y en a
d'autres et qui va te plaît ici celles
intervenues respectivement
merci beaucoup roi nomme rosio ni
médecins infectiologues à l'hospital
clinic de barcelone d'avoir été avec
nous en français dans le texte on vous
remercie et bientôt un nouveau sérum
disponibles peut-être le vaccin chinois
sinovac en lice pour être le cinquième
être autorisé dans l'union européenne
l' agence européenne des médicaments
doit évaluer si les bénéfices de ce
sérum l'emportent sur les risques
plusieurs études ont déjà remis en
question son efficacité les détails des
mayas souple et c'est le huitième
vaccins passée au peigne fin par l'
agence européenne des médicaments
ce mardi l'organisme a annoncé le début
d'un examen continu du vaccin chinois
sinovac pour évaluer son efficacité et
sa sécurité
si les résultats sont concluants il
pourrait arriver prochainement sur le
marché européen
la décision du comité des médicaments à
usage humain de commencer l'examen
continue est basée sur les résultats
préliminaires des études de laboratoire
et des études cliniques
l'ema évaluera la conformité du vaccin
que 8,19 inactivé avec les normes
européennes habituel d'efficacité de
sécurité et de qualité
l'évaluation d'une éventuelle demande
devrait prendre moins de temps que
d'habitude en raison du travail effectué
pendant la révision continue l'agencé
européenne des médicaments qui explique
aussi le procédé utilisé pour développer
ce vaccin contre le coc u19 celui dit du
virus inactivé le vaccin contient le
sera ce qu vite 2 qui a été inactivé et
ne peut pas causer la maladie
le vaccin commis 19 inactivé contient
également un
du vent une substance qui aide à
renforcer la réponse immunitaire au
vaccin
sinovac a déjà été autorisé au chili au
brésil en ukraine ou encore en turquie
mais son efficacité a été remise en
question par la chine elle même suite à
la publication d'une étude brésilienne
étude selon laquelle elle ne dépasserait
pas 50,4 %
les autorités sanitaires ont donc étudié
la possibilité d'utiliser deux vaccins
différents entre la première et la
deuxième injection
le 16 avril dernier une étude chilienne
accorder davantage de crédits à sinovac
estimant son efficacité à 67% pour
prévenir les cas symptomatique à 80%
contre les décès et 85 % dans le cas des
hospitalisations pour forme grave de co
vide
à titre de comparaison astrazeneca est
autorisé dans 65 pays alors que son
concurrent chinois n'est pour le moment
présent que dans 22 pays
cet examen continu de l' agence
européenne devrait donc éclairer les
zones d'ombré autour de sinovac et de
son efficacité
le g7 à présent les ministres des
affaires étrangères ont discuté ce mardi
d'un possible front commun face à la
chine au lendemain d'un dîner consacré
aux programmes nucléaires de l'iran et
de la corée du nord
les chefs de la diplomatie du club des
pays riches ont ouvert des discussions
formelles ce mardi à londres leur
première réunion en personne
en plus de deux ans a été consacrée à la
chine acteur économique incontournable
dont la volonté de s'affirmer comme une
puissance militaire et d'exercer son
influence dans le monde qui inquiète
donc les capitales occidentales mais
également à de nombreuses autres
thématiques internationales écouter me
concernant j'ai eu l'occasion de parler
avec mes collègues des négociations de
l'accord de vienne celui du nucléaire
avec l'iran
nous avons partagé avec le secrétaire
d'état américain blinken où on était
toutes ces négociations difficiles
toujours en cours à partir de vendredi
nous entamerons une nouvelle série de
discussions
j'ai également eu l'occasion de parler
de la situation en ethiopie en somalie
dans la corne de l'afrique où la
situation est très dure
euronews mais nous espérons que la libye
se souhaite une bonne nouvelle que le
cessez le feu est toujours en vigueur
je pense que nous pouvons être
optimistes
globalement les choses ne vont pas mieux
mais il ya des endroits comme l'iran
peut-être ou la libye nous pouvons avoir
un certain espoir d'amélioration et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
liverpool avec francesco rizzuto
professeur nos droits européens à
l'université et jill c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizzotto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
bruxelles qui suspend donc ses efforts
pour faire ratifier l'accord sur les
investissements avec pékin la commission
qui estime je cite que l'environnement
n'est pas propice à la ratification de
l'accord annonce donc du vice président
de la commission européenne ce soir
cette décision selon vous est elle en
lien avec l'orientation du g7 qui se
tient en ce moment à giovanni je les
passe je pense qu'il s'agit de poser de
basse politique concernant le
contentement des pays du g7
et ça pendant deux mignons européenne
quant à ce qu'il se passe en chine en
matière de droits de l'homme
ce droit des minorités c'est également
en matière de politique expansionniste
notamment en matière militaire dans la
région du pacifique alors anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a réaffirmé la volonté des
américains de maintenir l'ordre
international fondé sur des règles ans
selon ses propres mots l'administration
maiden tante elle clairement de
reprendre la main sur les relations
entre l'europe et les puissances
mondiales que sont la chine ou la russie
en 2002 sans doute que l'administration
byetone s'engage pour un ordre fondé sur
le droit
cela ne signifie pas que les états unis
ne vont pas défendre leurs propres
intérêts mais ils disaient qu'on peut
jouer aux cow boys comme sous
l'administration trump s'est terminée
administration byden nous qui pensent
comme les européens comme les personnes
sensées
il est mieux d'établir un ensemble de
règles et d'opérer dans le cadre de ces
règles a plutôt que de se fier
uniquement à la force économique ou
militaire
est ce que justement on peut croire en
ce discours d'établir des règles pour le
moment il n'y a pas une si grande
différence sur le plan de la politique
étrangère entre joe biden et et donald
trump a ainsi de one love ou yoox à
certaines maisons tout à fait raison je
pense mais la façon dont ces politiques
sont menées est légèrement différente
qu'il s'agisse de donald trump ou de
dubaï talus mais états unis ont des
intérêts stratégiques qu'ils vont te
vrai à préserver sous de nha trang
c'était un peu plus compliqué mais c'est
plus qu'un discours pour moi je pense
que je battais ni accepte la nécessité
d' accor généralisée consensus on a
besoin je suis d'accord avec la chine
avec la russie tout en préservant les
intérêts occidentaux et américains
donc pour moi c'est plus qu'un discours
souligne bien sûr les intérêts
américains et européens mais dans le
contexte européen et d'ailleurs
notamment lorsqu'on parle du royaume y
quelques titres exit par là d'un système
fondé sur les droits mais nous avons
également l'exemple du royaume lui qui
parle juste des jardins de cet ordre
international l'a fondée sur des règles
tout en ignorant certaines règles
certains accords qu'il a signés comme le
français des salles bien des règles j'ai
pu mais faut-il est respectée oui sinon
on les mines et vous et vous évoquez les
états unis et la russie
ce soir joe biden qui a pourtant traité
velimir poutine de turin tout de même
espère
inespéré et le rencontrer fin juin à
quoi faut-il s'attendre selon vous lors
de cette rencontre qui va peut-être un
donc se tenir entre vladimir poutine et
joe biden entre le président des états
unis et le président de la russie serait
une bonne chose
je pense qu'elle aura lieu deux fois il
s'agirait que je ne rencontre entre deux
réaliste politiques qui acceptent et
comprennent tous les deux doivent
trouver une forme de consensus afin que
les relations entre la russie qui serait
émergent en tant que grand pouvoir
européen et mondial on ne peut pas
renier et les états unis de we want the
world
depuis ce avant lieu nous voulons à
maulde prévisible stable notamment dans
l'ère post vide
donc je pense qu'il sera très fructueux
je me rappelle il ya très très longtemps
le président reagan a rencontré campagne
a fait tout le monde était très plaisir
et en fin de compte on va obtenir
d'accord et beaucoup de stabilité
donc malgré justement le vocabulaire le
langage du tueur etc
il est de l'intérêt de tous de trouver
des accords quant à la forme de l'ordre
mondial dans lesquels nous souhaitons
vivre chacun à un matériel et les grands
intérêts communs sur le changement
climatique la stabilité l'idée qu'on
puisse se tirer de tout tout seul c'est
illusoire
alors on tait nîmes dickens qui se
rendra également à kiev 1 pour témoigner
du soutien après le déploiement de
troupes russes à la frontière sur fond
de relations tendues avec moscou
le secrétaire d'état américain ce qu'il
est venu
également l'ombre pour s'assurer de
l'unanimité des membres du g7 sur la
position à adopter face à la russie sur
ce dossier ukrainien
archos g9
bien sûr cela fait partie de nos biens
de ces lieux il ne fait aucun doute qu
en euros qu'il ya eu des désaccords
concernant le positionnement à prendre
avec la russie car les intérêts publics
européens c'est très clair en tout cas
le secrétaire d'état américain veut
s'assurer que les alliés européens
souhaitent unis concernant la posture à
prendre vis à vis du problème ukrainien
et il veut s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
trop de fissures dans le blog mais je
pense qu'il y a d'autres aspects peu
dire que la russie à renforcer la
pression en ukraine afin de gérer notre
générer une réaction du côté européen
mais personne n'aurait intérêt à voir un
conflit en ukraine
il faut souligner le fait que vladimir
poutine va rencontrer que je file un
joueur juste car cela dans l'intérêt de
tous notamment dans ceux longue parce
que qu'ovide dans lequel nous entrons
merci beaucoup francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen à
l'université hadj il de nous avoir
apporté votre éclairage sur ce sommet du
g7 et voilà c'est
cette géopolitique et ses dossiers qui
seront abordés merci à vous le break
site à présent réponse à de nouvelles
restrictions de l'ons concernant l'accès
à certaines zones de pêche la france
envisage des mesures de rétorsion les
précisions de grégoire douce et la pêche
encore et toujours sujet de discorde
dans le dossier du breakbeat
alors que tout semblait entériné avec
l'accord commercial de sortie
définitivement validé par bruxelles la
semaine dernière des points
d'achoppement continue d'attiser les
tensions
au coeur du conflit les îles
anglo-normandes zone dont l'accès serait
plus contraignant pour les pêcheurs
français on considère que si de
nouvelles exigences pour les zonages de
mer où les engins de pêche sont intégrés
dans les dix ans alors même qu'elles
n'ont pas été notifiés à la commission
européenne
elles sont nulles et non avenues si le
royaume uni veut introduire de nouvelles
dispositions
il doit les notifier à la commission
européenne qui nous les notifie ce qui
nous permet d'engager un dialogue
ensuite à ce stade on a découvert ces
nouvelles mesures techniques qui ne sont
pas applicable en l'état à nos pêcheurs
les pêcheurs comptent justement sur
l'état pour envoyer une réponse ferme
aux britanniques
il est évident qu'il va y avoir des
réponses à l'agression dont nous sommes
victimes par les autorités de jersey par
rapport aux autorisations de pêche
on espère que l'état prendra des mesures
de représailles le message est
apparemment passé puisque devant
l'assemblée nationale la ministre
française de la mère annick girardin a
mis les choses au point
vous le savez dans l'accord il ya des
mesures de rétorsion eh bien ces mesures
de rétention nous sommes prêts à les
utiliser l'europe la france a des moyens
s'est inscrit dans l'accord nous avons
des moyens et même si je regrette si on
ne devait en iard est arrivé bien on y
sera s'il faut le faire
pour l'heure seule une quarantaine de
navires français équipés d'un système
permettant leur localisation en mer sont
autorisés à pêcher dans les eaux du
jersey
dans le reste de l'actualité le mexique
sous le choc après un terrible accident
de métro la nuit dernière bilan
provisoire au moins 23 morts 23 morts et
des dizaines de blessés à mexico après
l'effondrement d'un pont du métro aérien
au passage d'une rame
le président mexicain promet une enquête
approfondie françois xavier lambert une
rame de métro brisé en deux suspendus au
dessus d'un pont aérien en partie
détruit le drame s'est produit à 22
heures heure locale sur la ligne 12 du
métro qui traverse le sud de mexico
sur ces images de vidéosurveillance on
peut voir des pans entiers de la
structure s'effondre et au passage des
wagons au milieu des gravats et des
câbles des formes et les secours tentent
de venir en aide aux blessés les plus
graves mais aussi de retrouver les corps
des passagers tués dans l'accident
de nombreuses familles sont toujours
sans nouvelles de leurs proches
ma belle fille nous a appelés à l'été
avec son fils et elle nous a dit que la
structure s'était effondré sur eux mon
frère est venu avec sa femme ils ont
réussi à la faire sortir mais lui est
écrasée et nous ne savons rien ils ne
nous donnent aucune information il est
sous les décombres et maintenant ils
doivent le sortir qui sait combien de
temps ça prendra une émotion également
partagé par les autorités mexicaines
solidarité et fraternité avec les
familles touchées par la tragédie de ce
soir dans le métro et soutien au
gouvernement de mexico
des enquêtes doivent être menées et les
responsables doivent être déterminées
dans les plus brefs délais je serai très
attentive à ce qui est demandé ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui dans le métro
est une terrible tragédie
ma solidarité avec les victimes et leurs
familles bien sûr il faut enquêter sur
les causes et définir les
responsabilités
je me tiens à l'entière disposition des
autorités pour contribuer à tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour l'instant les causes
de l'effondrement ne sont pas connus
mais dès 2017 plusieurs témoignages
rapportés des fissures sur la structure
du pont que ce n'est également pas la
première fois que le métro de la
capitale mexicaine et le théâtre
d'accidents
en janvier dernier un incendie avait
endommagé les installations de contrôle
du réseau
les émanations de fumée avait provoqué
la mort d'une personne et en avait
blessé 29 autres en mars 2020 c'est une
collision entre deux rames du même métro
qui avaient fait un tué et 41 blessés
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans quelques instants avec
emilie gobin
quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtel c'est pas un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein au film ans on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham changer les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe preuve
j'étais le seul à pouvoir créer
induction d'une paix durable grâce à ses
relations différentes avec tous les
acteurs le problème est maintenant de
voir comment joe biden va traiter un
sujet s'il relance l'accord actuel des
accords d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]